[Music]
on Friday's show we made the point that
much of the news Americans are told is
factual turns out to be propaganda that
seemed like an obvious point human
beings lie that is their nature powerful
people tend to lie quite a bit in order
to protect their prerogatives
journalists who have the power to shape
perception are especially vulnerable to
dishonesty you watch them carefully
there's nothing especially controversial
about that observation it's obviously
true and yet maybe not surprisingly a
lot of reporters found it deeply
offensive Michael barbero of the New
York Times called it quote repugnant as
he put it it's quote literally damaging
to our democracy that anyone would doubt
the accuracy of his newspaper question
the New York Times and America falls
apart pretty funny in other news the
carrier Corporation has announced that
it's immoral not to use air conditioning
by our product or you're going to hell
in fact as is so often the case the
opposite is true skepticism is not
unpatriotic it is your duty principled
questions don't destroy democracy they
sustain it
the people in charge don't like to be
second-guessed and why would they a
skeptical population makes their lives
more complicated they'd like you to
swallow your medicine without complaint
shut up and obey don't ask questions
accept what you're told and get back to
work well that's a lot to ask especially
coming from the New York Times there's a
lot of interesting detail in that
newspaper day-to-day and good for them
for printing it but there's also an
awful lot of lying especially about the
big things remember the New York Times
spent an entire year assuring us that
Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction we went to war over that
many thousands died and it was a lie or
how about when The Times told us that
Barack Obama's toppling of Muammar
Qaddafi would turn Libya into quote a
productive partner with the West
we'll be interesting to know what the
family is now being sold in Libya's open
slave markets think of that prediction
and who can forget this Times headline
from the spring of 1975 when the camera
Rouge took over Cambodia quote for most
life well a third of the population went
on to die in genocide in Cambodia the
time says yet to issue a correction
nowadays The Times is hyping to Russia
hoax telling us that Moscow was the
greatest threat to this country when
it's clearly not the paper is trying to
provoke yet another pointless war in
Syria by pushing a claim but Bashar
al-assad gassed his own people Times
reporters pretend to know for certain
that that happened that Assad did it
they don't know that for certain once
again they're lying we could go on we're
not making a partisan point here by the
way the New York Times is hardly the
only powerful institution that distorts
the truth someday soon for example maybe
this week the Republican leadership in
the house may announce an amnesty for
more than a million people in this
country illegally they'll tell you that
letting foreigners ignore our laws is
good for America don't believe them
they're lying our country has changed a
lot and the divide is no longer between
Republicans and Democrats or even
between left and right it's really
between the incompetence in charge and
everyone else a small group of people
has become rich and powerful mismanaging
this country and in fact I've written a
book about them it's called ship of
fools it's out in the beginning of
October you can order it now if you want
but in the meantime remember you don't
reflexively owe anybody your allegiance
outside your immediate family and that
includes the news media you don't have
to hate the people in charge but be sure
to stay skeptical they lie a lot